[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
débat de france 24 en france après la
réélection la semaine dernière
d'emmanuel macron la gauche quand de
s'unir en vue des législatives de juin
une union voulue par la france insoumise
première étape hier soir le parti de
jean luc mélenchon et europe ecologie
les verts ont trouvé un accord le parti
communiste et le parti socialiste veut
poursuivre les discussions la gauche
mobilisés donc pour les prochaines
élections mais aussi mobilisés dans les
rues hier pour le 1er mai des milliers
de personnes se sont réunies un peu
partout dans l'hexagone au coeur de
leurs revendications le pouvoir d'achat
et la réforme des retraites des
manifestations parfois marquées par des
violences notamment à paris c'est
violent c'est cette mobilisation sont
elles alors les prémices de ce à quoi on
doit s'attendre pour ce nouveau
quinquennat d'emmanuel mâcon cette union
de la gauche si elle voit le jour
pourrait-elle entraîné une cohabitation
comme en tout cas le souhaite jean luc
mélenchon qui se voit déjà à matignon
quinn du rassemblement national mais
aussi de la droite et la droite qui
refuse de s'allier à la macro ni
peut-elle éviter son implosion dans ce
contexte on va débattre de tout ça avec
nos invités ce soir à frédéric dabi
directeur général opinion de l'ifop
bonsoir un soir à nungesser a également
avec nous en plateau éditorialiste à
atlantico coauteur de gérald darmanin
les secrets d'un ambitieux aux éditions
l'archipel à côté de vous un brice
couturier journaliste et essayiste
auteur de ok millennials son édition
l'observatoire bonsoir et puis michel
soudais rédacteur en chef adjoint de
politis bonsoir à tous les quatre on va
d'abord revenir si vous voulez bien en
images sur les manifestations d'hier
manifestations du 1er mai à paris il ya
beaucoup de dégradations et beaucoup de
violence on va en reparler juste après
des restaurants et des commerces
défigurée par le passage des casseurs de
nombreuses vitrines de ce quartier du
11e arrondissement
vandalisé lors de la manifestation
d'hier ce matin le nettoyage continuent
et la remise en état s'organise
la casse et
promet des planches devant
des devantures saccagés comme cette
agence immobilière prise pour cible par
plusieurs personnes à l'intérieur le
mobilier est renversé une catastrophe
pour les propriétaires
me suis effondré j'ai pleuré c'est de
ces trente années de travail ça ils ont
mis des papiers dessus-dessous gens
cassés des bureaux dehors la retrouver
un petit bout du feu du photocopieur d
écran cassé des disques durs on va
c'était lamentable dans cet atelier de
réparation de scooter le patron colmate
comme il peut là aussi des individus se
sont introduits dans l'entreprise et ne
sont pas parti les mains vides
il y avait un scooter en vitrine comme
on fait un peu de location de véhicules
y avait un scooter en location ils n'ont
ils l'ont sortie ils ont sauté dessus
voilà après mon bras tout le matériel
tout le matériel qui avait l'on volé un
déchaînement de violence contre une
vingtaine d'en scène notamment ce
magasin bio investi par des pilleurs
entré par effraction au total le
ministère de l'intérieur fait état de 54
interpellations
michel soudais cette explosion de
violence qu'on a vu hier on voit dans le
sujet les dégâts c'est symptomatique du
climat social aujourd'hui en france
alors d'abord en jeu je tiens à dire que
les dégâts sont réellement considérable
1 les locaux de mon journal se trouve
juste sur le parcours non pas sur le
boulevard voltaire mais juste derrière
et c'est des trajets qu'on fait
quotidiennement alors est-ce que c'est
symptomatique
écoutez ça existe depuis 2016
alors là des fois là les forces de
l'ordre agissent d'une certaine manière
et la violence se fait contre les forces
de l'ordre là elle semble t-il elles ont
décidé de laisser faire on les a
quasiment pas vu de toute la
manifestation
même si moi j'étais plus
particulièrement avec les politiques à
un kilomètre de là il faut quand même le
dire
mais en passant ensuite j'ai pu que
constater les dégâts alors qu'est ce qui
se passe dans ce genre de manifestations
pourquoi il y a à l'avant des
manifestations assez régulièrement ce
qu'on appelle un black bloc qui sont pas
forcément des gens organisés entre eux
sous forme politique mais qui adoptent
une stratégie qui est effectivement une
stratégie de cases de débordement de
manifestations et un ca on l'a depuis
2000 16 depuis la loi elle conneries
depuis que les syndicats ne sont ces
pagnes question qui serait délégitimer
ou autre c'est que le mode d'action
syndicale n'aboutit à aucune victoire
réelle c'est donc symptomatique d'un
climat social extrêmement tendu
aujourd'hui sur tout ça c'est surtout ça
c'est le fait qu' il n'y a pas la
possibilité de se faire entendre par des
moyens classiques ou en tous les cas
pour ces gens là 1 les moyens classiques
ce qu'ils appellent les manifs ballon
ans les journées de grève aux autres
n'amène à aucune victoire donc utiliser
d'autres méthodes c'est aussi ce que
faisait un certain nombre de gilet jaune
qui par la violence ont obtenu un
certain nombre de choses notamment un
quand emmanuel macron avait décidé de
verser une prime mais ce couturier c'est
un message à emmanuel macron ces
manifestations hier non c'est une
sinistre tradition française qui fait
que dans tous les manifestations
dorénavant ou le 1er mai pour le 1er
janvier j'veux dire il ya des casseurs
ils sont très nombreux mais on est en
cause ici la position des forces de
police mais je vais mettre en cause la
position du service d'ordre de la cgt
moi j'ai manifesté dans de nombreuses
défilé du 1er mai je me souviens qu'à
une certaine époque qui avait les gros
bras de la cgt qui l'est c'est pas les
casseurs faire n'importe quoi donc c'est
gentil d'accuser la police mais je me
demande pourquoi le service d'ordre de
la cgt lui aussi laisse légendes et des
trublions pillé volé cassé
tout ça au bénéfice de l'extrême droite
bien parce que ça renforce dans le pays
la demande d'autorité une demande
d'autorités qui est extrêmement forte
les sondages le montrent tous les ans et
en fait c'est ces casseurs travail au
profit de l'extrême droite de la droite
la plus radicale qui elle est là pour
nous dire qu'elle peut incarner
l'autorité quand il y en aura besoin
c'est très dangereux c'est une situation
très dangereuse anita auxerre le test
sécuritaire du gouvernement il a échoué
hier avec 7000 fans mais aussi le
mouvement social des casseurs parce que
les casseurs on les voit dans toutes les
manifs pas seulement depuis 2016 on les
a commencé avec le sommet de l'otan à
strasbourg où il ya eu la première casse
intensive si je puis dire en revanche
qui s'est passé hier c'est assez
incompréhensible effectivement parce
qu'aucun service d'ordre n'est
intervenue contre les casseurs ni même
il n'y a pas eu d'action préventive
parce que maintenant on essaie quand
même de les détecter avant qui se mènent
aux manifs sont des gens qui arrivent de
manière normale et qui après sow met à
casser quand il se mêle à la
manifestation en hand c'est pas que ce
sont des casseurs on les prend pour des
manifestants classique et puis ils ont
dans leurs oeufs dans leurs sacs dans
leur sac à dos des pavés enfin tout ce
qu'il faut pour pour casser la hier il
ya une controverse sur l'intervention de
la police dans moi je n'y étais pas je
ne sais pas comment ça s'est passé je ne
veux pas porter de jugement c'est sûr
que ça n'est pas normal ce qui s'est
passé hier alors voilà pour par rapport
au mouvement syndical je vois là voilà
pour les violences dans les cortèges
aussi frédéric dabi il y avait des
revendications sociales bien sûr
revendications notamment sur les
retraités et le pouvoir d'achat des
grands thèmes de la campagne
présidentielle
oui tout à fait c'est vrai que ça a été
relativement éclipsé en c'était pas un
1er mai anodin c'est le premier mec qui
a fait suite à une élection
présidentielle récente
traditionnellement le calendrier a été
avancé le 1er mai était souvent le
moment important de l'entre-deux tours
on se souvient de nicolas sarkozy qui
avait fait 1 contre 1er mai en 2012 qui
devait appeler ça la fait du vrai
travail si je ne me trompe pas et c'est
vrai que ce qui s'est passé il ya une
image qui n'est pas montré je ne vous en
veux pas mais c'est le pompier qui se
fait qui se fait frapper par ici c'est
une question de droit mais montrer 7,6
de l'adsa c'est une image qui choque
terriblement les français passaient
s'inscrit dans un continuum c'est une
stricte medic pour expliquer une stricte
mais dick qui s'en prend à un pompier
qui est en train d'être en mer mais
c'est vrai que pour les français c'est
le signe quand on regarde quand les
français spontanément pas dans des
sondages mais dans des enquêtes
qualitatives où il s'exprime
spontanément sur la question c'est
sécurité qui met en avant le fait que
les victimes entre guillemets d' actes
d'insécurité sont de plus en plus des
personnes dépositaires de l'autorité de
l'état dépositaire de l'autorité
publique c'est ce pauvre mère de signes
il ya maintenant presque deux ans le
chauffeur de bus de bayonne des pompiers
et médecins et c'est vrai que tout ça a
peut-être éclipsé ce qui était
effectivement un moment politique une
union de la gauche qui s'est quand même
affiché hier la
maison c'était pas très évident à
imaginer qu'ils ont encore quelques
semaines et puis comme vous le dites
très bien cette question qui touche le
salariat pouvoir d'achat et retraite et
si je dis salariat ce n'est pas anodin
non plus puisque c'est la seule
catégorie de population et à une est un
vrai match une vraie zone de
recoupements où marine le pen est arrivé
en tête au premier tour et elle a fait
quasiment 50 50 avec emmanuel macron au
second tour la france insoumise vous
l'avez évoqué elle était bien présente
aussi dans les cortèges hier d'ailleurs
jean-luc mélenchon n'a pas condamné
vraiment ces violences hier il a surtout
accusé le préfet de police d'avoir
laissé faire les casseurs on va écouter
tout de suite la réaction du ministre de
l'intérieur à ses propos de jean-luc
mélenchon gérald darmanin
monsieur mélenchon est aujourd'hui à peu
le pompier pyromane il refuse à
l'assemblée nationale les moyens pour
les policiers il veut d'ailleurs les
désarmer il veut empêcher d'avoir du
renseignement qui nous permet justement
de prévenir à certains de breda il de
faire nos propositions malheureusement
parfois qui sont censurés nous
respectons
droit et ensuite il dira se plaindre que
nous n'avons pas pu intervenir on peut
dire que jean luc mélenchon s'est emparé
de cette journée du 1er mai lui qui
arrivait en 3e place au premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle en politique
il s'en est effectivement en parler
maintenant distinguons dans le cortège
il y avait plusieurs phases 1
vous avez manifesté il ya peut-être
longtemps mais
certainement très longtemps mais le
service d'ordre de la cgt est en tête de
la manifestation et ce qui se passe les
casses ont lieu en tête de avant en aval
un donc le service d'ordre ne peut pas
avoir de responsabilités et quand il
quand il vise lui est arrivé
d'intervenir et de ses prix un des coups
extrêmement violent qui l'ont obligé à
de nouveaux sarn est en quelque sorte
pour résister à ces casseurs dont vous
avez un premier bloc 2 jean inorganisés
où il ya de la casse en général une
séparation entre les deux un espace vide
le cortège syndical c'est le 1er mai des
syndicats est en queue de manifestation
arrive les partis politiques de gauche
qui se joignent à la manifestation donc
sachant qu' il ne pourrait pas partir
assez rapidement dans les premiers de
cette manifestation jean luc mélenchon a
effectivement un organisé une sorte de
deux meetings un nom pas improvisées
mais avec tout ce qu'il fallait pour
prendre la parole devant une foule
extrêmement compact de gens
enthousiastes et ensuite est parti sur
la manifestation avec son cortège où on
pouvait voir là un certain nombre de
manifestants d'autres formations
politiques à se réjouir de voir
finalement qu'il pouvait y avoir une
union parce que ce ne sont pas la france
est pas uniquement la france a soumis ce
qu'il veut une union de la gauche ce
sont les électeurs de gauche
jean-luc mélenchon a été très habile
puisqu'il a organisé effectivement ce
meeting avant le départ de la manif et
donc on a eu le sentiment quand on
regardait les chaînes d'information et
elles étaient toutes à lui ils sont que
c'était la journée de jean luc mélenchon
et ce n'était pas la journée des
syndicats quand quand ton avis vous
confondez vous confondez donc je ne me
font pas je regarde où il rend compte
non le miroir c'est celui que vous
faites vous à celui que nous faisons
nous ce n'est pas la réalité à un moment
il faudrait bien quand même on prendre
conscience bien alors si vous dites que
c'est le miroir médiatique il faut dire
que jean luc mélenchon a pris la main
sur la manifestation
au détriment du social en par huit a le
1er mai non non c'est un défilé des
syndicats des forces sociales pas
d'effets politiques et en espèces
d'opéra de la part de mélenchon et en
même temps la crise est bien là et
manifs très bien même temps les
politiques il ya toujours des ratios
l'éthique il n'y a pas toujours eu des
meetings ou d une tribune de avant la
générale électorale bien sûr mais les
politiques prennent la parole pendant le
pendant la manif pendant qu'il est il
marche enfin j'veux dire on a quand même
l'habitude rsa là c'était une tribune
c'était un micro s'étaient organisés et
en même temps frédéric dabi aujourd'hui
les syndicats ne sont plus aussi
puissant qu'il ne l'était à 1h groupe
que 10% des salariés environ oui comme
tous les corps intermédiaires les
syndiqués dont 400 m est finalement
assez les syndicats mais reste quand
même un moment ritualisé qui est qui est
effectivement le moment où les syndicats
défilent font part de leurs
revendications c'est vrai qu'à des
revendications très fortes qui peuvent
porter c'est vrai qu'ils sont aussi gêné
par oui parce momentum particulier fans
campagne présidentielle et basculement
extrêmement rapide beaucoup plus rapide
qu'en 2017 2012 2007 ou 2002 sur la
campagne des élections législatives qui
en plus va durer deux semaines de plus
où les oppositions à emmanuel macron ont
lancé la campagne extrêmement tovar jean
luc mélenchon au soir du premier tour
comme si le second tour ni
au delà de l'erreur à matignon de leur
affaiblissement liens historiques et
c'est vrai que il ya la dernière grande
victoire syndicale c'est quand même le
cpe c'est en 2006 c'est quand même une
période assez anciennes ont perdu
beaucoup d'audience du côté du salarié
français qui comme j'ai dit au premier
tour et ça ne s'était jamais vu dans à
travers une enquête
aujourd'hui vote a mis en tête à
plaissan tête marine le pen ce qui n'est
quand même pas n'importe quoi alors dans
ce contexte de grogne sociale en tout
cas on l'a vu hier la gauche tentent de
s'unir en vue des législatives non plus
jean luc mélenchon donc hier dans les
cortèges à côtés d'olivier fort le
socialiste europe écologie les verts
également pour devenir la première force
d'opposition c'est son but en tout cas
et la nuit dernière justement la france
insoumise et europe ecologie les verts
ont conclu un accord qui le disent
historique on va écouter julien bayou
suivi d'eric bompard on va reparler
juste après
c'est pas forcément d'accord historique
lui dit que c'est exceptionnel en tout
cas que nous ayons réussi à nous mettre
d'accord pour ces législatives et que
c'est aux françaises et aux français
d'en faire peut-être un moment
historique je pense qu'on peut parler
d'un accord historique d'abord c'est
factuellement vrai il n'y avait jamais
eu d'accord dans l'histoire entre europe
ecologie les verts et la france a
soumise au niveau national pour les
élections législatives
et puis je crois que c'est historique
parce que ils enclenchent en tout cas je
le souhaite puisque on aura des
rendez-vous dans les prochaines heures
avec d'autres formations politiques il
enclenche j'espère le début d'une
dynamique qu'est ce que tu ris et c'est
historique 7 c'était presque c'est là
c'est l'alliance de la carpe et du lapin
comme en europe ecologie les verts
peut-il s'allier avec un parti
antieuropéen comment le parti socialiste
qui va peut-être s'allier qui est un
parti pro-européen qui est un parti
libéral et social démocrate peut-il
s'allier avec un parti populiste
d'extrême gauche qui ne respectent pas
la laïcité qui est anti européen enfin
cesser tout cela on voit bien que c'est
une manif une manie possède une
manipulation électoraliste de bas niveau
jusqu'à présent la vie politique était
d'une certaine manière une politique
centrifuge une vie politique centrifuge
dire que on cherchait il y avait le
parti socialiste et le et le parti
républicain enfin ça s'appelait de
manière différente dans le temps mais
enfin quelque part on cherchait à avoir
les électeurs centristes électeurs
modérés s'étaient eux qui faisait
basculer là on venait une politique
complètement polarisé comme aux états
unis avec la gauche extrême dominant la
gauche modérée la droite extrême de
marine le pen dominant la droite modérée
c'est une situation extrêmement
dangereuse a évidemment elle est
extrêmement bonnes pour macron emmanuel
macron cdu c'est du gâteau pour lui
parce qu'effectivement face à face à
deux extrêmes faut pas s'imaginer que la
totalité des électeurs de gauche du
premier tour des présidentielles vont se
retrouver derrière derrière mélenchon
c'est une illusion bien entendu de même
de même
par contre par contre l'extrême droite
elle est très puissante donc je pense
que c'est une très mauvaise opération de
la part du ps je vois pas des gens
raisonnables comme j'ai pas cazeneuve
hollande le foll courir décrire mêlant
chez les participants s'est divisée ça
serait grotesque attendait les électeurs
socialistes ne marcheront pas dans cette
je vous écoute mais c'est quoi votre
métier vous êtes caricaturiste non je
dis la série vous allez voir le résultat
des élections p1 qui respectent pas la
laïcité vous vous moquez du monde quoi
non c'est ça c'est ça le fatigue il a
d'abord lire la loi sur de séparatisme
et là c'est pas une oie qui défend là
ils ne respectent pas les consignes je
vous signale que la plupart des ses
coûts et la quasi totalité des
organisations de défense des droits de
l'homme dans ce pays
la ligue des droits de l'homme la
défenseure des droits notamment ont
critiqué vertement cette loi parce
qu'elle attentes aux libertés
d'association 1 qu'est-ce que vous
voulez que je vous dise de plus alors un
vous êtes
vous est obnubilé par un combat un que
vous en gens vous prenez d'air dans
l'ehpad marine le pen et vous aller dans
le même sens faites attention bien sûr
on
va pas revenir sur le sur le programme
de jean luc mélenchon dans le détail
frédéric dabi cette alliance en tout cas
entre europe ecologie les verts et la
france insoumise finalement ça acte une
sorte de recomposition de la gauche
aussi autour justement de la france est
soumise qui a fait plus de 20% à 2
citrons bar qui avait parlé qui avait
dit quelques années que avant par de
parler de recomposition il y avait un
phénomène de décomposition céret faut
pas oublier à quel point nous vivons un
phénomène de décomposition parti loin
d'être dite en 2012 la 18e à la
candidature en 2012 l'addition des
pourcentages hollande sarkozy faisait 55
% en 2022 l'addition des pourcentages on
peut parler aussi des voix pécresse anne
hidalgo faisait à peine 7% après ce qui
vient de se passer c'est vrai qu'il ya
un phénomène de recomposition à gauche
et à droite c'est vrai que jean luc
mélenchon peut bénéficier d'une envie du
peuple de gauche des sympathisants de
gauche qui ont connu un troisième 21
il a qui l'on promet et c'est une
question d'automaticité on sait très
bien que depuis 1997 depuis que il ya eu
au début des années 2000 à cette
invention du calendrier électoral les
législatives ont perdu leur effet leur
autonomie l'effet de souffle
présidentielle jouer c'est à dire qu'on
a à chaque élection législative depuis
2002 un différentiel de participations
entre le camp du vainqueur qui veut
confirmer son choix de la présidentielle
et le camp des électeurs des candidats
pardon ayant été des faits qui sont
démobilisés là ce qui est très
intéressant c'est qu'on est peut-être
dans un cas nouveau une campagne plus
longue une campagne qui a commencé
beaucoup plus tôt un deuxième mandat
pour la con ce qui est moins facile pour
un président élu on se souvient qu'en 88
françois mitterrand l'avait emporté
avait eu une main une majorité somme
toute relative mais quand même là où je
rejoins ce qu'il a dit par brice
couturier c'est que au delà des accords
d'appareil qui n'intéresse pas les
français il ya quand même sur beaucoup
de sujets des différences
programmatiques tels que la question qui
se pose c'est est ce que ses électeurs
de gauche vont jouer l'idée d'un d'une
victoire de la gauche aux législatives
ou devons regarder les programmes les
dix les différences et ne pas
rééquilibrer leurs scores dedans une
enquête ifop fiducial pour sud radio
moins de 32 33 % je crois ou 34% des
français souhaiteraient que j'ai avec
mélenchon accède au poste de premier
ministre cette question n'a aucun sens
mais la programmation des jeunes
mélenchon avait elle même aucun sens en
termes institutionnels
on va écouter tout de suite en tout cas
ce qu'en pensent les électeurs de gauche
qui ont été interrogés ce matin à lille
ce qu'il pense de cette de ce début
d'alliance à gauche entre europe
écologie et les verts et la france
insoumise de jean luc mélenchon pense
que c'est clairement ce qui nous
manquait et est ce qui a fait qu'on
n'est pas passé loin aux présidentielles
je crois que c'est un peu dommage d'y
retourner en ordre dispersé comme on l'a
vu un peu aux présidentielles je pense
qu'il faudra calmer un petit peu les
ardeurs de monsieur mélenchon et essayer
de trouver un consensus
est ce que cette cette alliance est ce
qui manquait vraiment comme on a entendu
cette première personne c'est ce qui
manquait à la gauche pour gagner la
présidentielle cette union de la gauche
vanité auxerre non je dirais était
inimaginable avant le début de la
campagne
présidentielle que l'ailé tous les
partis de gauche se range sous la
bannière de jean-luc mélenchon il a fait
une très bonne campagne il est arrivé
troisième il ya aujourd'hui trois blocs
politiques il faut bien le reconnaître
et il ya effectivement une grande
frustration que jean lemelin politique
donc rassemblement national l'extrême
droite à l'extrême droite on appelle
l'extrême agonie à dire là ma chronique
y va du modem jusqu'à territoire de
progrès et et la france a soumises
il ya trois ans et ça c'est déjà une
nouveauté qui ont d'ailleurs je trouve
dans les médias en parlent que de jean
luc mélenchon depuis une semaine s'est
il ya les deux autres même ça serait
mieux en parler et vous mais j'adore on
n'en parle pas parce que les c'est ça
qui est assez pas surprenant mais pour
l'instant la macro ni c'est à dire le
n'est pas entré en campagne il ya les
personnalités qui s'expriment dans les
médias mais les investitures ne sont pas
faites on ne sait pas quelles sont les
accords entre la république en marche et
les partis qui soutiennent emmanuel
maquilleuse demain il ya eu des
négociations hier entre des proches
d'edouard philippe avec oui mais enfin
pour le moment il ya ça paraît assez
compliqué juste j'ai juste ajouté que le
parti radical de gauche aujourd'hui a
fait savoir qu'en aucun cas il ne
soutiendrait les candidats de jean-luc
mélenchon pour les raisons que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure d'ailleurs vision
radicale pour les raisons que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure on vous allez aussi
l'écart était normal parce qu'il a dit
laïcité tout à l'heure à la cité europe
parti radical de gauche c'était un parti
qui entend qui quand il était parti
radical a joué un rôle important dans
l'histoire de notre république depuis la
quatrième c'est terminé l'ancien juste
pour dire ce
même vous êtes une survivance quelque
part oui je vous remercie bon vous
savez assez bas ce soir exclusion condé
je peux me permettre sinon on essaie de
débats très ferme a dit un ancien vous
dit holland cazeneuve des gens
raisonnables c'est les fossoyeurs de la
gauche dans
l'ancien un communiste un bon communiste
un communiste mort pour vous un bon
socialiste c'est un socialiste qui
n'existe plus qui ne mène pas une
politique sociale il à la
social-démocratie et et y aller à la
gauche radicale elle existe la
social-démocratie l histoire on va
écouter fabien à l'échelle locale les
régions les départements et les villes
sont dix minutes parallèle comme celle
ci au existe à l'échelle locale c'est
les frondeurs quand tu es le ps
on va écouter tout de suite fabien
roussel pour le parti communiste qui ce
matin disait lui aussi espérer un accord
avec la france en soumises alors certes
un peu certains partis donc souhaite
souhaite cette alliance en vous l'avez
dit les radicaux n'en veulent pas on va
écouter tout de suite fabien roussel et
on en reparle après je souhaite que nous
puissions signer ensemble un contrat de
législature ensemble les quatre forces
principales socialistes communistes
insoumis écologistes que nous signons un
contrat de législature ensemble montrant
aux français ce qui peut changer dès le
mois de juillet
voilà une alliance du parti communiste
anita auxerre avec la france a soumis sa
va pas changer grand chose mais la
question n'est pas là c'est que le parti
communiste c'est à toujours été proche
du parti de gauche de qui est qui est
devenue la france a soumise mais c'est
pas la question la question c'est est ce
que tous les partis vont signer un
accord de législature c'est à dire le
parti socialiste qui au parti communiste
et la france a soumise
le parti communiste et la france
insoumise c'est ça ne change rien au
paysage politique en 2017 si je peux me
permettre il ya quand même une volonté
des insoumis de faire disparaître le
parti communiste assemblée nationale
parce qu'il y avait un refus juridique
mélenchon de de poursuivre très déçu par
sa défaite de peu mais il était quand
même 4e de poursuivre le combat des
élections les déchets si avec ce que dit
fabien roussel tu as quand même assez
intéressant est en rupture avec la
campagne présidentielle donc on peut moi
je pense qu'il ya des différences
programmatiques qui vont être plutôt
gênante mais du point de vue du fin du
du discours des principaux leaders qu'on
vient d'entendre il ya quelque chose qui
change et c'est vrai qu'il peut y avoir
un effet d'entraînement dans un contexte
où les français beaucoup de français ne
sont pas sur une logique de laisser de
tous les pouvoirs au président réduit et
on va coûter on va écouter tout de suite
olivier faur pour le parti socialiste
juste avant le début de la réunion tout
alors justement avec la france en sont
mises pour un éventuel accord
je suis venu rappeler ce que sont nos
exigences pour le parti socialiste parce
que nous considérons que c'est une
grosse partie ce n'est pas simplement
une histoire
témoignage on a déjà beaucoup fait à
cette fois ci on est sur une aventure
qui peut être une aventure
extraordinaire qui peut changer la vie
des gens mais à une condition c'est
qu'on garde un équilibre dans tout ce
qu'on fait donc négocié l'accord de
coalition
comprendre à la fois
les coûts sur le fond sur le projet je
suis athée j qu'on va poser ensemble
dans l'élection législative et puis sur
le pluralisme aussi de cette coalition
c'est tous ces points là sont importants
et il faut que l'on puisse avancer chez
soudé beaucoup d'hésitation pour le
parti socialiste on peut comprendre ses
hésitations en cas de
de d'alliance avec la france insoumise
et pour disparaître le parti socialiste
oui il n'y a pas de plan b un très
clairement je peins on ne voit pas
comment le parti socialiste s'il partait
seul pourrait un garde et un groupe
parlementaire même c'est à dire 15
députés
là les discussions sont d'après ce qu'on
nous dit sérieuse elle porte sur
l'accord programmatique et stratégiques
qui pourraient être mis en oeuvre après
il ya aussi des discussions sur les
circonscriptions
le parti socialiste d'après ce que je me
suis entendu dire n'est pas celui qui
est le plus
gourmand en terme et le plus insistant
sur les répartitions de circonscription
sauf pour ses sortants ce qui n'est pas
le cas un du parti communiste qui lui a
fixé son objectif en conseil national à
plusieurs reprises notamment le 14 mars
on peut s'y référer ses écrits 1
l'objectif au législatif c'est 700
milles c'était 700000 vois pas autre
chose il ya les réalistes et les autres
je veux dire le parti socialiste et son
groupe ils sont 33 à l'assemblée
l'assemblée sortante je veux dire s'ils
reviennent à 33 ils seront contents le
parti communiste
ils ne sont pas case ils ont l'apport
des députés d'outre-mer qui forme qui
leur permettent de former un groupe
autonome je ne sais toute la question la
formation d'un groupe mais quand je vois
que fabien roussel est prêt à mettre
sous le boisseau la question du
nucléaire s'interroge c'est une question
qui est relativement marginale à vous
trouver
elle n'a pas été fait marginale dans la
campagne de fabien roussel qui en a on
en a beaucoup son camp se sont en fait
focaliser sur les propos sur la viande
des choses anecdotiques qui ne dépare
fait mais on skie l'a dit sur le
nucléaire c'était pour lui une vraie
ligne de fracture avec l'offre
programmatique de jean-luc mélenchon le
véritable problème d'un que les
électeurs recensés que alors c'est pour
ça qu'il n'y aura pas forcément le
mécanisme qu'on a pu avoir sur des
législatives qui suivaient les
présidentielles c'est d'habitude les
pains depuis 2001 les gens votaient au
législatif porté par un élan par le
dynamisme d'une campagne par l'espoir en
un projet en un homme providentiel et il
voulait donner une majorité à cette
personne là on cherche vraiment où est l
élan le dynamisme le projet a on ne peut
plus flou et les les députés qui vont se
présenter seront désignés par le roi
macron parce que finalement on est dans
la résidence
non c'est pas la même chose
c'est lui qui va les désigner au final
d'où le problème on n'en parle pas
beaucoup effectivement dans cette future
majorité qu'il voudrait mettre autour de
lui c'est quelle place pour les partis
autour on voit qu'il ya des grosses
bisbille avec horizon le parti d'edouard
philippe peut-être que ces frondeurs
fait dur seront là la semaine existent
mais mais bah oui mais il va des députés
il veut des députés et là il veut pas
l'offre emmanuel macron un rossini à lui
en donnait donc dans tout cet espace
tous les gens qui ne veulent pas de la
politique sociale annoncée des manuels
magon 1,2 des services publics malmenée
notamment le projet sur l'éducation
nationale est complètement fou à tous
ces gens là plus les salaires le pouvoir
d'achat et bien ils se reportent sur
leurs espoirs sur la gauche c'est votre
les coutures et non
risque curieux oui non évidemment le
problème c'est qu'on va se retrouver
avec une assemblée nationale dans
laquelle il y aura deux oppositions très
forte effectivement une opposition
d'extrême gauche l'imposition d'extrême
droite et je trouve que ses propres
problématiques parce qu'effectivement on
était habitué à avoir des oppositions
qui était relativement constructive
parce qu elles convergent est quand même
sur un projet gouvernemental quelque
part en tout cas sur certains aspects ce
projet gouvernemental quand on avait le
rpr au pouvoir ou le ps au pouvoir
quelque part il y avait des moyens de
moyens d'aboutir à des consensus sur des
textes importants parce qu'il y avait eu
il y avait une majorité d'idées si vous
voulez qu'on pouvait mobiliser là on va
se retrouver avec une assemblée
nationale extraordinaire ont polarisé
avec un blog d'extrême gauche je compte
je maintiens et un autre d'extrême
droite et dans entre lesquels entre
parents parenthèse là encore le
maquereau va jouer sur du velours parce
que ces deux blocs d'opposition ne
pourront être d'accord sur rien en
réalité à part sur des mots d'une motion
de censure de temps en temps qu'il ya
peu de chances d'aboutir mais entre
l'extrême droite et l'extrême gauche il
ya très très peu par bonheur jusqu'à
présent deux points comme sur
permettront d'avoir une position commune
jusqu'à ce que pour l'instant on ne
parle que de mélenchon mais n'oublions
pas qu'on à 33 % d'électeurs d'esprit
concernant l'extrême droite justement
avec le mode de scrutin pour les
législatives que peut espérer le
rassemblement national qui refuse toute
alliance avec reconquête des reconquêtes
n'existe que dans l'esprit parce que
eric zemmour a fait un score beaucoup
plus faible que ce qu'il escomptait
aujourd'hui c'est le front national où
le rassemblement national pardon qui a
la main leur conquête n'aura
pratiquement pas de pas de député eric
zemmour a un qui dit que marine le pen
veut la mort de son parti
il voulait la mort de marine le pen donc
mais pour répondre à votre question
c'est vrai que ce qui va se passer sans
doute aux élections législatives y aura
une abstention plus forte cas d'élection
présidentielle je rappelle contre la
présidentielle de 2017 et hull city 2007
il ya eu 28 points de plus d'attention
et pour la première fois sous la vème un
public une abstention majoritaire tout
ça n'est pas anodin parce que ça a des
conséquences sur le seuil de
qualification pour le second tour douze
ennemis % des inscrits prenons une
circonscription moyenne avec 50%
d'abstention j'espère qu'elle aura moins
mais c'est une éventualité envisageable
ça veut dire que le ticket d'entrée pour
le second tour si on n'est ni premier ni
deuxième
c'est 25% ce qui veut dire très peu de
triangulaires donc des configurations
compliqué pour le rassemblement national
je rappellerai qu'entre 1988 la victoire
de yann piat dans une élection
législative partielle dans le var et
2017 quelques victoires y en a eu six ou
sept du rn aux élections législatives en
duel le rn n'a jamais gagné en duel
pendant plus de trente ans c'est vrai
que sans doute le débat soit
proportionnelle sur la mauvaise
représentation d'un parti qui a fait 13
millions et demi de voix au second tour
d'expérience elle ne manquera pas de
rebondir et donc dans cette polarisation
vous faites c'est plutôt le bloc de
gauche qui aura sans doute beaucoup plus
de députés que le bloc est reine
reconquête qui effectivement on n'aura
pas même dans la conquête mais c'est
aussi c'est aussi sur une analyse
politique que fait marine le pen marine
le pen est extrêmement présidentialiste
et considère il fallait les entendre le
soir du premier tour le soir du deuxième
tour et ça a dû vous plaire monsieur
couturier qui voulaient pas qu'on qu'il
vous voulez pas je les lui partout qu'on
conteste quelque part la légitimité ou
l'importance du score des manuels mâcon
ils ont considéré emmanuel macron à
gagner maintenant on va aux législatives
on va faire une opposition 1 il n'est
pas question pour elle de prendre un
tant soit peu le pouvoir on reste dans
les caractéristiques de la famille le
pen c'est tout ou rien est plutôt rien
du moment que la petite boutique peut
continuer à tourner et qu'on a le
financement public des partis politiques
pour acheter des boulons des tournevis
et resserré toute la machinerie le pen
ou des tas de d'élus fui régulièrement
quand ils sont élus locaux 1 c'est un
épouvantail un bien gênant un bien
pratique pour emmanuel macron bien
gênant pour la gauche mais c'est un
épouvantail c'est surtout le mitterrand
qui en avait fait un épouvantail bien
pratique sur le plan électoral qualité
aux serbes voulaient réagir
partage pas tout à fait votre analyse
mais bon voilà
il y aura une opposition de droite bien
sûr vous croyez que parce que marine le
pen le rassemblement national part seul
en campagne et il fera beaucoup moins de
vous à moi de dd lui que le que la
gauche s'est fait sans doute sans doute
bien sûr on va écouter la question cette
semaine là que la vraie question c'est
quelle sera la majorité est-ce que
emmanuel macron il est venu vers moi
est-ce que emmanuel macron frédéric la
vie doit doit craindre une cohabitation
justement avec cette gauche qui est en
train de s'unir alors c'est pas fini il
ya encore des tractations mais est ce
qu'on peut craindre est ce que le chef
de l'état peut craindre un tel scénario
c'est un scénario qui n'est pas
inenvisageable c'est vrai qu'il ne s'est
jamais produit quand la présidentielle
précédait d'élections législatives en 80
prenons un cas historique il ya la
fameuse victoire de fraude de françois
mitterrand la droite se dit on va créer
une nouvelle boutique qui s'appelait lui
nm ou non pour une nouvelle majorité ils
surfent les français vont être terrorisé
d'avoir élu françois mitterrand et ils
éliront massivement des députés de
droite on sait comment ça s'est terminé
une cohabitation n'est absolument pas
impossible moi je pense que l'effet de
souffle présidentielle jouera quand même
mais on est sur une incertitude beaucoup
plus forte qu'en 2017 pour toutes les
raisons qu'on a évoqué ensemble ce sens
il ya une force politique qu'on n'a pas
du tout évoqué ce sont les républicains
qui ont eu comme le ps un score
catastrophique et des élections
présidentielles et public à qui refusent
de sa villa toutes sont 103 députés
alors certains vont aller chez reyl
macron ça absolument évident il ya déjà
eu quelques signes qui ont été donnés il
faut pas oublier que les députés
républicains aient lieu en 2017 ont été
élus par gros temps dans un contexte où
c'était très compliqué aussi d'être élu
quand vous venez du ps ou des
républicains et la plupart sont très
bien installés implantée non pas dans
des grandes agglomérations des grandes
métropoles nous ont déjà complètement
disparu mais dans des zones rurales dans
des halls la france périphérique où le
fn est fort mais ça pourrait être par
rapport à des sortants bien implanté des
réserves de voix pour le second tour et
aussi bien la gauche que la macro ni ne
sont pas en situation de force alors
bien sûr des républicains ne gagneront
pas on peut le dire les élections
législatives et pourrait être aussi si
il ya une crainte de voir du côté de la
droite et dames accroc ni de voir la
gauche revenir et gagner et 110 ch
hâtives ça pourrait être l'effort sur
scène hier le mentionne une force
charnière comme comme le sait entre la
caf et entre 80
ouais delattre est le fruit d'une
nouvelle d'une nouvelle si je puis dire
configuration et qu'on recomposition
politique de la même manière qu'ils ne
seraient pas du tout imaginé
inimaginable que le bloc bourgeois et
l'appui pour contourner le bloc de
gauche
le national
le bloc bourgeois
ah bah oui c'est un peu les forces au
milieu ce qu'ils vont bien les bien
nourris et bien logés les bien rémunérés
alors qu'autour sa galère dans une
france où la pauvreté augmente parce que
la politique qui a été suivie depuis le
départ c'était de favoriser les
actionnaires de favoriser la finance
eric de quoi qu'il en coûte a beaucoup
fait louis c'est le conte la dépense
sociale s'étend sur monsieur la dépense
sociale le paie le montage de ces idées
plus élevé d'europe c'est en france
alors ne faites pas le coup de la france
sans qu'il soit
parce que qu'emmanuel macron va faire un
certain nombre de gestes sociaux avant
les législatives
pour l'instant il n'est pas réinvesti
quel type de geste il pourrait faire le
chef de l'état en faveur du pouvoir
d'achat alors on parle de chèques
alimentaires on parle de mesures pour le
pour le
carburant moi je suis pas dans le secret
des dieux mais je veux dire c'est sûr
brrr qui rend qu'il y aura des
déneigeurs la prime la fameuse prime à
laquelle je crois moyennement la prime
macron pas ce que ça veut dire que les
employeurs
veulent bien donner 7 7
c'est comme les employant voulait pas
lâcher attendait d'échec on c'est à dire
qu'en fait du clientélisme
on voit là se dorer on peut faire une
loi on peut décider de faire ce qu'ils
appellent ce qu'on appelait autrefois la
participation pour les gens soient
intéressés mais pour que les
travailleurs soient intéressés aux
bénéfices des entreprises moi j'avais
existe ça va ça va être développé ça va
être à moi je pense qu'on est ce parce
que dans les phases et qu'on va entrer
dans une période de guerre quand on a
besoin d'un chef de guerre qu'on va
avoir une économie de guerre et que
toutes les promesses qui ont été faites
dans la démagogie ambiante de cette
campagne électorale ne pourront pas être
tenues parce qu'il va falloir reconverti
rassemble des chaînes de production pour
fabriquer des armes et des munitions ce
qu'ils ont dans sont une période très
dure je dois dire que pareil heures moi
je souhaite une cohabitation mais pas du
tout celle de monsieur moncaut frère de
chez politis je souhaite que à matignon
il ya un vrai chef de gouvernement que
le président république se consacre à ce
qui devrait être son métier c'est à dire
les affaires étrangères la défense parce
que nous entrons dans une période où on
a besoin d'un chef de guerre à l'elysée
ernault zana chef de gouvernement et les
journalistes télé aux hommes que
rich and ivory cadré - dans quelques
semaines comme vous allez voir ce qui va
se produire donc moi je souhaite un chef
de guerre à l'elysée je souhaite un chef
de gouvernement à matignon appartenant
au même parti de préférence évidemment
parce que la macro nice une grande
famille mais je pense que c'est ça qui
va se produire et non pas les ce que ce
succès les promesses électorales les
promesses sociales correspond pas à la
personnalité c'est moi c max et mon
questionnement
frédéric dabi on l'a vu on n'a pas de
vous je suis pas sûr frédéric dabi on
l'a vu on a parlé beaucoup pouvoir
d'achat retraite c'est ce qui préoccupe
aujourd'hui les français et brice
couturier l'a évoqué il ya cette guerre
ans en ukraine on n'envoie pas encore
toutes les conséquences aujourd'hui en
france ça risque de de s'inviter à la
rentrée dans l'agenda politique c'est
déjà oui c'est déjà là mais au cours
elle sait déjà c'est déjà fait invité
cette année encore toutes mes vacances
et qui a été structurée autour du poêle
achats il ya un avant et un après guerre
en ukraine notamment sur les prix du
carburant notamment sur le sentiment de
relégation beaucoup ça existe avant mais
ça a été amplifié le sentiment de
relégation que vivent beaucoup de
français sur le mode est ce que ça vaut
la peine que je prenne ma voiture pour
emmener le gamin à son club de sport ou
pour aller retirer de l'argent quand on
voit le coût de l'énergie le prix du le
prix du carburant
oui ça pénalise encore une fois les
français qui doivent prendre mais c'est
la question de l'inflation mais je crois
qu'ils vont à 4,8 pour cent de ses
créations et qui s'était jamais vu ces
deux enquêtes qualitatives avait disparu
de discours des français mais au-delà de
ça je suis frappé de voir le niveau
d'intérêt toujours très élevé et pas
seulement cantonnée aux diplômés à des
classes sociales entre guillemets
moyenne ou supérieure sur les questions
internationales ukraine intéresse
énormément parce que on voit pas on
anticipe des conséquences concrètes pour
le pays et même pour sa vie il ya eu une
guerre il ya une guerre que les
électeurs de gauche et écologistes
aimerait bien voir mener c'est la guerre
qu'on le réchauffement climatique et
celle là emmanuel macron ne l'a pas
véritablement abordé et il n'en prend
pas tout à fait le chemin
[Musique]
c'est la préoccupation première
actuellement voyez-vous relais français
probable pour les plus jeunes beaucoup
mondial il ya l'idée de planification
écologique 6 6 a manifestement vous
voyez que dans les idées de jean luc
mélenchon y en a qui peuvent être prises
mais la reprise le montant le moment oui
de temps en temps on peut reprendre
bientôt tentant des choses qui sont pas
complètement folle d'autres quand il
s'agit d'islam au gauchisme je suis
beaucoup moins preneurs car confiant ça
n'existe pas ça va bien ça n'a aucun
sens si des défis
lancés par des zigotos et je vois que
tout le monde me reprend sans être
capable de donner une définition à sucer
la case là encore l'alliance de la carte
sert du mccarthysme que vous menez avec
ce terme là points et
ceux qui sont dans le déni sont
précisément ceux qui sont les plus
concernés bien entendu
il nous reste quelques minutes
j'aimerais à une dernière réaction
de vous tous sur sur ce qui va se passer
sur les législatives un pronostic
absolument pas non moi je pense qu'on
est sur une campagne incertaine beaucoup
plus que les campagnes précédentes pour
toutes les raisons que l'on vient de
voir et la question centrale pour moi ça
va être la mobilisation électorale
l'abstention sera plus forte cas
d'élection présidentielle est ce qu'il
ya un sursaut du peuple de gauche pour
imposer une cohabitation questions
furent et stéphane sociale elle va être
centrale oui mais la question sociale
est déjà centrale et puis il ya quelque
chose quand même con à part en tête
c'est que on a évoqué les différentes
sortes on n'a pas évoqué le fait que
mails macron va être en mouvement on
connaît sa plasticité quid de la
nomination de son gouvernement
quid de l'ouverture qui pourrait faire à
gauche et à droite tout ça pourrait
avoir un impact on se souvient très bien
les faits edouard philippe avait quand
même grandement participé à une fortune
en 2017 au fait que les français proches
de la droite avaient voté très fortement
pour les candidats dans marche mais on
n'est pas je pense sur une réédition du
scénario de 2010 est jusqu'où cette non
réédition ira personne ne peut le dire
en 2017 il y avait une fracture au sein
de l air à cause de la ligne identitaire
contre la ligne sociale démocrate
voulaient mais là ça n'est pas le cas on
ne voit pas aujourd'hui une personnalité
de gauche devenir premier ministre
mais ce qu'on te rien dernier mot oui le
monde dans les mots c'est que évidemment
je souhaite que beaucoup d'électeurs
sociaux démocrates socialistes
traditionnel haug radicaux de gauche
rejoigne la majorité présidentielle
parce que c'est leur destin
écoutez je pense que c'est cette
législative va nous réserver quelques
surprises et en tous les cas pour ce qui
est de la mobilisation je pense que en
lançant sa campagne pour une idée de
premier ministre parce que c'est
rappeler l'article 20 les le caractère
essentiel des législatives un jean luc
mélenchon a bien joué il contribua et
les partis de gauche enclenche derrière
à mobiliser un électorat de gauche qui
ne doivent pas considérer cette élection
comme acquise pour emma donc le
défaitisme n'est plus dans ce qu on la
reprend tous les cas rhinite allergique
rien n'est joué parce que effectivement
emmanuel macron et sa majorité ne sont
pas entrés en campagne pour le moment
merci beaucoup merci frédéric dabi mme
cecilia nita auxerre merci brice
couturier merci michel soudais d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir sur france 24
rester avec nous l'information continue
[Musique]